so the most important part for me was
that car driving would be still
affordable
and climate friendly
from 2035 new cars that are placed on
the market they should be zero emission
we're not saying okay you have to sell
your car and buy a new car we're only
saying that in 2050 we would like to see
that also the transport sector is carbon
neutral
so also class classic cars race cars and
the cars that you have now you can run
your car until the end of the lifetime
the most important part for me was that
car driving would be still affordable
and climate friendly and this is what we
want to achieve with this legislation
that's electric driving for example is
not only for the rich people also other
people can afford an electric car
2035 is 13 years from now and car
manufacture already saying now it's
doable to place new cars on the market
that are serial Mission and that they
should focus on developing the zero
Mission cars and not anymore for example
an internal combustion engines